bonjour ce n'est pas une autre façon de commencer salut
mon nom est David Raskin j'ai 17 ans et je
postule pour la bourse de physique du MIT
mes intérêts résident dans la physique des particules physique
théorique astrophysique physique quantique
je vois quantique je vois la
physique quantique quand j'avais sept ans  vieux mon
père m'a donné cette montre ouais Quinn je suis
parce que je suis occupé un mot pour
me décrire travailleur acharné
deux mots optimisme je suis très opulent
oui je promets que je travaillerai plus dur en
fait la raison principale pour laquelle je veux
aller  Le MIT est parce que je me souviens avoir
grandi et vu mon père travailler sur ses
projets et faire tout ce qu'il pouvait avec les
sciences appliquées qu'il a apprises du
MIT Je pense que c'est tout ce qu'il a toujours voulu
pour moi, il est parti depuis longtemps
et je pense qu'il est temps pour  moi pour ramasser
cette torche, je vais le rendre fier d'une
manière ou d'une autre alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je ne vais pas vous le dire encore d'accord, pouvez-
vous voir la tache, je parie
[Musique]